how is it possible that the best
performing stock of the last 30 years
isn't a tech company while companies
like Amazon apple and Nvidia have
created billions of dollars worth of
value by bringing new Innovative Tech to
Enterprise and consumer audiences they
still aren't number one in fact the best
performing company of the last 30 years
does one simple thing extremely well
they sell caffeinated sugar water that
Slims your options down but it isn't
Coca-Cola or Pepsi it's Monster Energy
since their IPO in 1990 monster has
grown by almost 200,000 % to put this
into perspective if you invested $10,000
into monster you would have made 19.2
million on the flip side if you were to
put $10,000 into Amazon you'd get $1.4
million less now of course monsters
started as a penny stock so insane
metrics like this are easy to hack but
this type of sustained success over a
30-year time frame is no fluke how is
this possible monster isn't Just Another
Cinderella Story for business owners to
gawk at in fact there are four key
lessons that when implemented correctly
will amplify the momentum of your
business how does a company perform so
well and get so little time in the
spotlight the news cycle is constantly
dominated by Titans of Industry like
Jeff Bezos Mark Zuckerberg and Elon Musk
yet we never hear about the founder of
monster and while we're at it who the
hell even is the founder of monster
Morgan and Morgan Law Firm is set to
file more than 100 lawsuits against the
makers of drinks like monster tonight a
lawsuit alleges one of those energy
drinks could be linked to a death beyond
the spreadsheets and stock market the
birth of monster is an amazing story of
shrewd marketing effort endless
controversy Fierce competition and of
course sleepless nights this is the
secret history of Monster
Energy the monster we know today exists
because of the Iron Will of one man that
man is Rodney Sachs now if you've never
heard of Rodney Sachs don't be shocked
he keeps a relatively low profile and
stays out of the news he doesn't even
have social media it's nearly impossible
to find any information on the
73-year-old billionaire he's never taken
an interview about his life and keeps a
laser focus on building the monster
brand not his own personal brand but
once you do the research you'll find
that his story should be studied by
every wouldbe entrepreneur Rodney was
born in 1949 in Johannesburg South
Africa to Jewish Lithuanian immigrants
Rodney had a typical South African
upbringing and didn't really show any
particular signs of being a future
billionaire he didn't go to fancy
schools like Harvard or Stanford instead
he stayed in South Africa and studied
law at a local University but it was
when he began his career his true
trajectory began to show itself after
graduation he took a job at South
Africa's largest corporate law firm and
Rose through the ranks like a rocket
during his tenure he became the youngest
person ever to be promoted to partner he
stayed for 20 years and eventually
became a senior partner of the firm
where many would ride off into the
sunset of their career but not Rodney
Rodney had been to the top of the big
law Mountain he'd achieved a level of
prestige that law students spend their
lives dreaming of he then realized it
wasn't for him as Peter teal said big
law is a strange place after years of
Devotion to his craft Rodney had come to
the same conclusion he wanted wanted to
start fresh so like many entrepreneurs
he packed up his belongings his family
and his career and moved to Southern
[Music]
California the year is 1989 Indiana
Jones in the Last Crusade is one of the
top movies of the year the 49ers
defeated the Bengals to win Super Bowl
23 and most importantly the Berlin Wall
fell signaling the end of Communism in
Continental Europe countries that once
had baring grocery stores are now seeing
rapid amounts of growth and new globally
produced products quickly one big winner
starts dominating the fry Red Bull gives
you wings Red Bull was the model of
global success the original Red Bull was
named cting D it was a working-class
staple in Thailand after some ingredient
adaptations carbonation and intense
marketing efforts Red Bull became
Europe's favorite drink clubs from
Manchester to Munich stocked the
beverage and it fueled a vibrant party
scene well it wasn't until 1996 and 1997
that Red Bull would sell its first can
in America and South Africa respectively
Rodney had noticed the trend and it
peaked his interest but Rodney was
convinced his opportunities lay in
another product category smoothies at
the time smoothies were huge in the US
jamb Bice was one of the hottest brands
in the country and lines were down the
block Rodney saw the chance to produce
bottled smoothies that could be sold
anywhere and everywhere gyms convenience
stores swimming pools and health stores
this would be his big catch only one
issue stood in his way Rodney owned
nothing in the United States so he did
what any firsttime entrepreneur would do
and started raising money Rodney and an
associate went to their friends and
family and raised 6 Mill ion dollar to
acquire a publicly traded shell company
this shell company would serve as a
vessel to raise even more money and
acquire an existing player if Rodney
wanted to bring a new smoothie product
to Market he would need one thing and
one thing only Distribution on his own
he couldn't pull all the pieces together
there had to be a business out there
that had a killer distribution network
but found itself on Hard Times Rodney's
big opportunity came to him through an
introduction by an investment banker the
missing puzzle piece would be a business
named Hansen's Hansen's was a staple of
old Hollywood established in 1935 Hansen
got their start providing juices to
movie sets the business was a family
affair and as a result never became more
than a regional success they built more
manufacturing facilities to get into
different verticals like foods and sodas
but never quite reached Nationwide
popularity in 1988 after a period of
aggressive overexpansion Hansen's had to
file for bankrupcy they sold off their
manufacturing capabilities to Tropicana
to pay off some of the debts and had
their name acquired ired by the
California co-packers Corporation while
many would see Hansen as a dead company
Rodney saw a diamond in the rough it had
the one thing he needed distribution
Hansen's pre-existing independent
distribution Network would give him a
proper Foundation to build his smoothie
Empire all he needed to do was turn
around the operation and launch the
Smoothie line from there it would be
smooth sailing or so he thought so in
1992 with his heart set on Hansen's
Rodney and his partner purchased the
business for a grand total of $14.5
million now that's almost double the
amount that Rodney and his associate
raised so how' they get access to 14.5
million so quickly the most likely
answer is that the investment banker
that they were working with set up an
lbo or leverage buyout working with the
bank Rodney and Co took out debt to
finance the acquisition remember how
Elon worked with Goldman Sachs and JP
Morgan Chase to purchase Twitter same
principle before the ink dried they were
losing money by the minute and only had
12 employees the first four years of his
time as CEO included consolidating cost
to put Hansen on the road to
profitability the launch of the Smoothie
line shortened the Gap towards profit
credibility in the first 9 months of
sales in 1995 the Smoothie line brought
in onethird of the company's Revenue the
next year Hansen was able to report a
profit of
$375,000 the very next year Red Bull
launched in the US and quickly became
the number one player in the category a
title they still hold today what had
only slightly caught Rodney's attention
before was now knocking on his door the
Hansen's executive team was excited
about this new category and they quickly
launched their own product with minimal
branding and a little bit of work in the
lab Rodney launched Hansen's energy with
a skinny 8.4 fluid ounce can in 1997 to
some Fanfare but it wasn't a slam dunk
success like Red Bull was over the
course of the next couple years Hansen's
energy spawn new flavors and energy
Blends they tested out torine ginsing
and even creatine which you've probably
seen in modern Energy Drinks like bang
while Hansen's energy was a moderate
success it was being targeted to the
wrong audience drinks were touted as
functional beverages with near medicinal
benefits the drinks would supposedly
fight aging or give consumers stamina
the company focused too much on the
herbs and additives in their drinks and
by association resonated with the health
conscious Market what Red Bull knew was
that the real money was in the 18 to
25-year-old male market energy drinks
struck the biggest cord with them and
they would become almost like
missionaries for the brand after years
of average performance with Hansen's
energy Rodney went back to the drawing
board and started thinking of ways to
really compete with Red Bull they needed
a total makeover Rodney and his team
upped the caffeine content increased the
sugar and high ired a killer brand
designer to give them something extreme
the result is the original
Monster as opposed to the 8.4 ooun can
Red Bull used monsters sold 16 oz cans
the Insight was simple this is America
bigger the better you can't have a
dainty little can and expect to win the
18 to 25-year-old male Market you need
something with some heft additionally
Hansen's offered retailers the same
wholesale price as Red Bull so they
would sell for the same price on the
Shelf as a consumer you could either
have the 8.4 fluid oun European Red Bull
or you could have nearly double the size
with a 16oz American monster for the
same exact price it was a no-brainer
alongside more value to the consumer
monster began an allout marketing Blitz
on the retail front monster had amazing
retail displays these displays spoke to
the extreme ethos of the brand and
included elements like NASCAR dirt bikes
and later on video games the brand also
made specialty coolers exclusively for
storing monster products at scale these
types of activations add up and monsters
soon found themselves with great footing
in retail monster was flying off the
shelves one business owner loved working
with the brand so much that he
commissioned a custombuilt metal display
rack for his gas station but their
efforts went beyond retail monster
copied Red Bull's Ambassador Network and
launched it on college campuses across
the country you couldn't go to class
without an ambassador giving you a can
of the new drink however the Cornerstone
of their strategy was in the form of
promotions the early marketing thesis
for Monster was simple if an 18-year-old
guy in the '90s thought it was cool then
monster would sponsor it on the extreme
sports side monster put their logos on
all sorts of equipment dirt bikes
skateboards snowboards then they jumped
into music acts like Suicidal Tendencies
and corn were given wristbands with a
monster logo and were paid to drink out
of monster cans on stage but more often
than not they weren't even drinking
monster they were drinking water just
out of monster cans it was a great
branding move monster became a massive
part of the late '90s early 2000s
cultural Zeitgeist and their revenue
reflected that going into the mid 2000s
monster entered a period of rapid growth
the Beast was finally Unleashed
hey diecast want to pick me up after the
launch of monster in 2002 Hansen sales
more than doubled and profits quadrupled
from that point forward it was Grind
Time for Rodney and the team the most
important objective building out the
sales and marketing team to move more
product at the time of the launch of
monster Hansen's employed 108 total
employees with the marketing and sales
department housing about 66 employees in
2005 that number jumped to 293 total
employees with 27 employees in marketing
and sales just a huge amount of
salespeople that increased headcount
came with increased growth in 2005
monster had captured 18% of the total
energy drink market and while Hansen was
still in Red Bull Shadow they were on
the path to eclipsing them with a growth
rate of 3x more now is the time to put
the pedal to the metal Hansen's began
experimenting with other flavors and
Brands to drive more Revenue products
like Joker mad energy Roomba Samba Tango
and lost energy hit shelves Across the
Nation but delivered mild results Jer
was nearly identical to monster with two
changes one there was a slight variation
in taste and two it was only sold in
Circle K convenience stores Joker was
more of a success for Circle K than it
was for Monster so the brand was sold
off to the convenience store chain in
2010 but that wasn't the only fat being
trimmed in 2010 after years of low sales
monster discontinued the product line
and Roomba Samba and Tango were no more
lost energy was discontinued the same
year the problem with all these
beverages was that they weren't standout
hits like the original monster hands had
spent a fortune building brand Equity
with their monster name so why not use
it the only way to launch new and
successful products was to stay under
the brand umbrella drinks like Monsters
zero sugar and monsters zero carb were
aimed at the health conscious crowd that
were originally captivated by Hansen's
energy monster Java and Monster Rehab
took notes from Roomba Samba and Tango
released coffee and tea blends to become
part of consumers morning routines the
executive team realized they didn't have
to rely on other brands like lost to
sell their product monster had had the
brand that moved the product they stuck
to the monster brand and now all of
these products are successful and still
around today in a final Changing of the
Guard in 2011 the business ditched the
Hansen's name and became Monster Energy
they found something that worked and
they were going to stick to it more
shelf space for Monster turned into more
lines of Revenue and monster was
entering its Heyday but that success
came at a cost we've all heard it before
the energy drinks Wen the best thing for
your health but now some say they may be
killing you is there a consideration to
putting an age restriction on energy
drinks absolutely we're looking at the
possibility of defining it as 18 or
older or 19 or older the number of
people who go to the emergency room
after drinking energy drinks has doubled
monster was thrust into a big
controversy as public health concerns
began to dominate the airwaves
regulators and the media were going for
their throats it wasn't long before
Rodney saak found himself in a
congressional hearing explaining the
safety of his beverages to bureaucrats
but this regulatory attention only
played into monster hand monster became
edgy all of a sudden monster was the
drink your parents your teachers and
your Congressional Representatives
didn't want you drinking Monsters Target
demo loved that they liked being part of
something that felt countercultural but
monster was only getting started after
the hearing the FDA issued a letter
stating that they would not be taking
any action against monster or any other
energy drink Brands monster shares
surged 133% upward without The
Regulators on their back monster began
to mature and grow as a brand in 2014
monster had finally reached full
maturity and Coca-Cola signed a deal to
acquire a
16.7% stake in Monster for a total sum
of 2.15 billion and become monsters
primary distributor this wasn't a
defensive move against Regulators but
rather an offensive move to keep
increasing monsters growth in the world
of beverages Koke has the single best
distribution Network ever the saying
used to be all roads lead to Rome but
today it's more like all roads lead to a
Coke distributor this move embedded
monster into Coke's International
distribution system in a way that would
pour gasoline on Monster's International
growth in other words monster now had
the tools to take on Red Bull around the
world all thanks to Coke monster isn't
Just Another Cinderella Story for
business owners to gawk at in fact there
are four key lessons that when
implemented correctly will amplify the
momentum of your business the first
lesson is brand adherence branding is a
big deal imagine this scenario if Nike
announced they were going to open a
hotel you'd have a clear idea of what
that would look like there would be an
awesome gym a massive sports memorabilia
Museum an expert taught Fitness classes
available around the clock that's the
power of a real brand now imagine if
Hyatt Hotels said they were going to
make a shoe I couldn't even tell you
what color the shoe would be in this
situation Hansen's was Hyatt and monster
was Nike remember back to the launch of
Hansen's natural energy while the energy
drink Market was wide open for
opportunity Hansen's energy just didn't
speak to the Target consumer the product
landed flat on its face now remember
when monster launched their first new
products outside of the original Monster
those weird Brands you've never heard of
like Tango and Samba similar to Hansen's
Natural Energy The Branding didn't
entice Target consumers enough and the
products were a flop develop a damn good
brand and stick to it lesson number two
distribution is as if not more important
than product at every turning point in
Monster's history there was a clear
focus on distribution think back to when
Rodney was looking to acquire a business
he didn't buy Hansen because the name
sounded nice or he was interested in the
history of the company he bought
Hansen's because they had everything he
needed to build a successful smoothie
brand a solid distribution Network then
with the launch of monster Distributors
made sure to set up eye-catching retail
displays and price monster competitively
with Red Bull that launch was a sinker
swim moment and the Distributors were
like a life preserver for the brand now
with monster as a mature brand they're
partnering with Coke the world's best
Beverage distributor to take a swing at
the number one energy brand third lesson
go where your customers are monster 's
early successes partially stem from its
Elite Marketing but their process wasn't
very complicated if anything it was
Ultra simple monster built its entire
brand and marketing strategy around its
customers while Red Bull had mastered
what European 18 to 25-year-old males
liked they didn't have an intimate
understanding of the US consumer like
monster did monster was sponsoring
everything an 18-year-old in the 9s
would think was cool working backwards
monster identified their Target customer
18 to 25-year-old males and then ask
themselves what does this demographic
like and where do they hang out from
there they spent money making sure that
there wouldn't be any 18 to 25-year-olds
who didn't know what monster was by
focusing so intently on their customers
monster built more than a drink brand
they built a cultural Force deciding
what was and wasn't cool but there's a
big question of how how did Rodney know
what would resonate with 18 to
25-year-old American males when Rodney
bought Hansen's in '92 he was A
42-year-old lawyer from South Africa he
wasn't some snowboarding skateboarding
BMX riding Rock star he was just a guy
who practiced corporate tax law arguably
one of the most uncool areas for someone
to work in how did he know what would be
cool how did he build monster into a
cultural Arbiter this brings us to our
fourth and final lesson the importance
of an open culture Rodney rarely gives
interviews in fact finding any
information about him online is a
massive struggle as I said before Rodney
keeps a very low profile he has no
social media accounts but in 2011 Rodney
gave beverage industry.com
a tell all and when No Holds Barred in
it he gives away the secret of monster
success he says everyone is able to
share their views and make
recommendations from the most Junior
guys up we think everybody should be
able to express their views and they
should be respected when people say how
do you come up with new products we
listen to the younger guys a lot of them
are internal what are they doing what do
they like when we test our packaging and
promotions we run it by the younger guys
the key to finding the right product or
packaging for the right demographic is
hearing what they say and understanding
them in their own environment as opposed
to trying to figure out what an
artificial Focus panel says but that's
not the end if we stop there the story
is that Rodney built monster into a
Powerhouse brand partnered with
Coca-Cola and then rode off into the
sunset while fitting for a novel that's
just not the reality the last couple of
years have seen heightened competition
in the energy dream Market from all
directions Red Bull is still the
dominant player in the arena with 42.5%
market share in the US while new
entrance are springing up by the day the
new kit on the Block to watch is Celsius
focused on serving Fitness enthusiasts
their drink provides more caffeine than
a monster while at a fraction of the
calories Celsius is owned by PepsiCo so
they're directly at odds with monster
however Rodney has a plan he's going to
take the market by force starting with
bang energy now if you're unfamiliar
with bang they serve the same customer
segment as Celsius but with more
aggressive marketing and more caffeine
basically an updated and modernized
monster their branding is loud and out
there there and the caffeine content of
one can of bang is equivalent to two
cans of monster but what sets them apart
from the rest of the market is their
heavy investment in influencer
promotions in 2022 bang energy spent the
most on YouTube brand Partnerships of
any company in the food and beverage
category but their focus isn't just on
YouTube they're also crushing Tik Tok
the company's official hashtag bang
energy has close to 20 billion views
leading the company is Jack AOK who is
the brand personified he wears Gody
pattern shirts paired with large bang
logo chains and is always stirring up
controversy remember folks if you ain't
training you ain't gaining if you ain't
banging you ain't hanging does this say
Yes to the Dress or say yes to the
breast so if you have a creatin peptide
you can solve mental retardation as we
age now you don't have to be an expert
in FDA regulation to Guess that Jack's
statements might cross a line but it
wasn't Regulators that took him to bat
over it it was Monster back in in
September of 2018 monsters sued bang
energy alleging that the company was
intentionally misleading customers and
fraudulently hyping up the benefits of
its super creatine the case was a home
run for monster and in September of last
year bang was forced to pay
$293 million straight to monster this
may have been a bump in the road if
PepsiCo Bang's former distributor wasn't
also awarded $15 million doll settlement
from bang the company was In Too Deep
with all of these settlements adding up
bang had to declare chapter 11
bankruptcy they were in a rough spot and
they were close to shutting their doors
but this wasn't the end of Bang's story
guess who was there to pick up the
pieces Rodney in July a judge gave the
green light to the acquisition of bang
energy by Monster Energy allowing bang
to steer clear of chapter 11 bankruptcy
monster now owns one of the hottest
names in the market and they were able
to buy it at a discount because of the
shrewd legal moves the stages are set
for Celsius and bang to clash but if I
were Rodney I'd be careful do you
remember how I said monster was the best
best performing stock of the last 30
years well with the help of the Pepsi Co
acquisition Celsius is the best
performing stock of The Last 5 Years I'm
doing a whole series on these kinds of
businesses so subscribe if you want to
see more and thanks for watching